in this video is sponsored by War
Thunder
back when I started this channel I made
a video about why skyscrapers are a bad
idea and they are however a few people
disagreed with me how will you solve the
housing crisis without skyscrapers they
asked you can't just put everyone in
single family housing such criticism
showcase stay very skewed
america-centric understanding of cities
and urban planning and they could be
forgiven for that looking at your
average core-centric American city like
Detroit you might notice something funny
can you see what's wrong here's
Frankfurt Germany for comparison do you
get it now in Detroit the high-rise
Center immediately transitions into
single-family neighborhoods in Frankfurt
the skyscrapers are surrounded by
mid-rises buildings that are between 5
and 12 stories tall if we go further out
the mid-rise areas turn into
multi-family home neighborhoods and only
at the edges of the city do you get your
single family home areas still
interspersed with multi-family
development and while mid-rises and
multi-family homes are ubiquitous in
European cities they are often outright
banned in America by local zoning codes
this is most often referred to you as
the missing middle though the term does
not include mid Rises only buildings
from duplexes up to smaller apartment
buildings the missing middle and
mid-rises is a major problem for a
number of reasons especially during an
ongoing housing crisis in many U.S
cities the first problem is
transportation people in the US used to
have options bike street car train tanks
planes battleships what's this oh yeah
War Thunder War Thunder brings the most
robust all-encompassing vehicle combat
ever featuring more than 2 000 tanks
planes helicopters and ships in online
player versus player combined armors
battles the vehicle roster spends more
than 100 years from the 1920s all the
way to present-day Motor Vehicles each
of them is detailed perfectly down to
the last bolt which provides for fun and
immersive gameplay instead of
traditional hit points the vehicle used
Dynamic damage models meaning they take
damage on their specific components or
crew members which determines whether
you survive a hit or not upon damage or
destruction a damage x-ray will show you
exactly what happened to your vehicle
I've been playing more and more with
planes recently dive bombers and strike
aircraft mostly but I don't shy away
from the occasional dogfight in
particular I like the diversity of air
battles you don't have to go fight
players in a PVP battle if you don't
want to you can also do bombing runs
against targets or enemy computer
controlled Vehicles hell you can even
shoot them with your machine gun also
the playing controls just feel fluid and
natural which is rarely most worthy in
games War Thunder is available for free
on PC Xbox and Playstation both latest
and previous console Generations use my
link in the description to start playing
and get a large free bonus pack of
multiple premium Vehicles a premium
account boosters and more thank you for
checking out War Thunder they support me
making more content for you now back to
the video so the first problem that
comes with Banning mid devices at
multi-family homes is transportation in
much of the US instead of mid devices
and multi-family homes local governments
incentivize sprawling single-family home
areas and by incentivize I mean they ban
everything else these neighborhoods are
car Centric by Design houses are spread
out so Transit stops cannot have good
coverage commercial areas and amenities
are are far away meaning the only way to
get to them is by car in sprawling core
Centric suburbs everyone has to drive
leading to soul-crushing traffic that
only gets worse each year one thing that
could help solve this issue is well
functioning public transit but it's
impossible to build it in such
neighborhoods what good is a Transit
stop if it's an hour walk away from your
home in multi-family and mid-rise areas
public transit suddenly becomes viable
as more people live within convenient
distance of stops leading to actual
ridership this is how old trem suburbs
were built in the U.S and they are some
of the most sought after areas to this
day in Europe new neighborhoods are
thankfully planned with public transit
in mind usually anyway there are
exceptions but new neighborhoods
generally have both single and
multi-family homes and some sort of bus
or tram service unlike in the US where
you get the usual sprawling
single-family home desert and the best
thing is in areas with proper public
transit and even bike infrastructure
more people will live core free or at
least they'll leave the car at home more
often leading to less traffic and less
congestion thereby everybody wins the
second problem of banning mid-rise and
multi-family areas is business or the
lack thereof in sprawling single-family
home areas residential housing is all
you get with commercial space clustered
around unpleasant Road arteries
surrounded by oversized parking lots if
you want to go shopping you can't just
pop by the corner store and get what you
need you have to get in your car and
drive a good 15 to 20 minutes to get to
the one Walmart in your area in contrast
you can turn multi-family homes and
mid-rises into mixed-used buildings
meaning you allow people to have
commercial or office space usually on
the ground floor of the buildings what
this does is decentralize Commerce
meaning instead of one enormous
corporate control shopping complex you
have lots of smaller stores owned by
locals but many American local
governments simply forbid you from
starting a business in a residential
building if you want to turn your garage
into a small store or convert a ground
floor section in an apartment building
into a restaurant or something the
government often won't allow it why
because of restrictive U.S zoning codes
allowing for residential buildings only
this big government overreach stifles
small businesses and forces you to shop
at the giant corporate shopping Box by
the highway not a good way to go if Time
Travelers arrived from the ancient or
Medieval Era their biggest shock
wouldn't be our modern technology rather
that we aren't allowed to have
residential space and commercial space
in the same building the third problem
with not allowing any mid Rises or
multi-family homes to be built is the
damage it does to society having to
commute by core is expensive the fuel
the maintenance the insurance the risk
of accident they all add up to a hefty
sum this is doable if your middle class
are higher but anyone poorer will have
trouble footing the bills especially if
their only housing option in an area is
a single family home and they have to
live in such a neighborhood otherwise
they'd be far away from their workplace
this creates a major artificial hurdle
in front of low-income households in
addition since starting a business from
your garage is literally banned in most
single-family home neighborhoods that's
one less way you can escape from poverty
even if you have a great business idea
but perhaps the biggest societal damage
here is the loss of so-called third
places in third place is where you spend
your time when you're not at home or at
work it can be anything from a cafe a
pub a community center a barber shop
take your pick it's a place where people
from all walks of life spontaneously
come together and mingle in a local pub
for example you might have a middle
manager a plumber a pensioner and a
college student all sitting by the bar
next to each other this is important
because proximity and contact create a
bridge between different segments of
society friendships are made connections
are established and it's generally good
for business turns out the middle
manager is looking for a Craftsman so
then a plumber can exchange contacts
also the college student is offering
tutoring on the side and the pensioner
does have a grandchild who's in need of
just that you get the idea but the most
important thing here by far is the
aforementioned bridge between groups if
you encounter members of another group
frequently and have positive or even
just neutral interactions with them you
are far less likely to develop
prejudices against them this keeps
Society together against the atomizing
force of foreign Fabric in the networks
looking to break Society apart into
different groups for their own political
ends neighborhoods with multi-family
homes and mid-rises are the perfect
terrain for such third places and they
help create a strong cohesive Society
more equal as Mobility is no longer put
behind an auto industry paywall and a
more environmentally friendly with
cleaner air and quieter streets and
Courtyards that are safe for children to
play in they also make for great worth
on their reps quick reminder use my link
in the description to start playing to
get the large free bonus back and join
the battle I'll see you on the ground in
the air or on the water depending on
your preferences now thankfully more and
more cities both in the US and Canada
realize the need for missing middle and
mid-rise housing and Zoning codes are
being reformed and that's great since
both multi-family homes and mid-rises
are the fundamental ingredients for
creating Pleasant safe workable and
bikeable neighborhoods reachable by
quality public transit where in addition
real estate will retain its value
throughout the years contributing to
people's wealth in a significant way not
to mention prospective buyers will have
a greater selection of housing to choose
from neighborhoods with mixed single
family multi-family and mid-rise housing
are just better in every aspect it's
time we went back to building those
instead of the usual sprawling
single-family hellscape thank you for
watching if you like my content you can
consider subscribing to my channel for
more videos like this and I also have a
patreon link in the description where
you can even support me monetarily if
you think my content is worth well
supporting monetarily and I'll be seeing
you next time